thank you
hey everybody and welcome to an elite
wild ride with Stevo we've got according
to ESPN the number one pound-for-pound
fighter in the world Alexander
volkanovsky what an unbelievable treat
this is and I think that we're going to
generate some headlines within the MMA
Community because we talk about some
pretty controversial stuff so strap on
your seat belts and let's get into it
all right so here we go ladies and
gentlemen Alexander the Great
vulcanovsky
yeah dude man I love this thank you so
much
um I just went ahead and blasted you a
DM on Instagram and uh that's how we got
through and and thank you for for doing
this man well I always thank you it's a
it was a blowout haven't you uh
instantly not Instagram message me and
I'm like what Steve I've been a big fan
for a long time so well thank you it was
cool to see so I appreciate you reaching
out likewise dude I I uh I love your
work
and uh
we've just had you go for double champ
status
that fight happened in Perth and
the day of that fight I was flying to
Las Vegas for a random gig and I thought
maybe Dana White wouldn't be bothered to
fly all the way to Perth so I hit up
Dana said him looking for a place to
watch the fight in uh in Vegas and Dana
said come on over to my house oh well so
we show up at Dana White's house me and
my my girl Lux and uh
I mean I I probably shouldn't say it too
much but you pull up and there's like a
guy with a gun
armed security don't let me do it it's
like
you know Billionaire Boys Club over
there it was a lot of fun and we watched
your fight together uh against Islam did
you watch the prelims at Dana's he he
told us to come over uh about 6 p.m were
you like
Steve watches every fight starting at
the prelims all the way to the end so
when you're at the when you go to the
adventure there oh yeah
for six hours yeah I love that yeah it's
great
um and uh it did the praise that Dana
gave for your fight you know he says you
couldn't ask for uh a better a better
fight my God
and uh Joe Rogan thinks he won the fight
against Islam
um no matter what like that that was a
great thing for you yeah for sure you
know it was uh obviously always going to
be a challenge you know there was a
reason why I was Underdog everyone was
thought I was crazy doing it yeah on you
uh you know I knew I could do it I
wanted the challenge because I knew not
only it's a big opportunity for me but
it's only going to make me better
they're going to make me stronger and
it's something that I feel like I could
could accomplish anyway and this this
close you know what I mean uh we we
thought we thought we did enough uh but
it was such a close fight uh you know
obviously that's why there's people that
you know thought I won and obviously
people that thought oh Islam one but
that's as Dana I heard Dana talking
about it like that's that's what you
want from a super fight too people
battling it out for pound for pound
number one right and it goes down to the
wire you know what I mean like and the
way it went you know it was definitely
you know my stocks are definitely still
Rose after that one 100 especially
finishing the fight the way we did you
know what I mean so 100 it's pretty
crazy my favorite favorite thing too
um
I I should say one of my least favorite
things when I'm watching MMA is people
getting stung by a shot and then they're
like no no that was not them they're
something you know yeah and my favorite
thing about watching you fight is that
when you get clipped you're like yep
that was a good one like you acknowledge
it it's funny it's funny you mentioned
that it's something that I'll actually
wanted to talk about because I haven't
uh no one's really asked me about that
so that's how I am I'm
I'm my hardest critic and you could
probably see that from when uh you know
in a post-fight uh press conference and
things like that the way I'm I'm talking
I'm uh I'm always gonna be hard on
myself you know I I know when I get hit
and I remember those because I don't
want to get touched you know what I mean
so you touch me I'm like yeah so usually
even when they land it's not even like
it's all that hurt me or anything it's
just
I seen it coming and you still got me
it's more like ah well done well played
yeah because yeah like I literally play
this game and you know I'm known for my
fight IQ and it's like it's a chess
match right and then sometimes they just
get like you know they might get me off
beating they're just like ah nice you
know so I acknowledge it yeah good you
got me all right so it's it's funny that
that'll do that but it's a weird one
where
uh again you you like that a lot of
people like that for me it's like that
but I mean I don't know how that looks
on the judges
so I'm worried like a lot of people like
on ISC people acknowledge and it makes
it look like oh yeah that was a really
good one so there's ones where he's like
shorter turning away and where I'm
sitting there like wouldn't wouldn't be
too hard of a shot but I'm like ah you
still got me well done you know what I
mean and then everyone remembers that
and there's ones where I felt like I was
Landing but like and he would like sort
of go away and
where I would think that that would
probably score more because he's like
you know me I'm like yeah cool you know
what I mean like I'm okay with it it's a
tricky one question it is a tricky one
so I might have to stop it my coaches my
coaches got angry at me about it wow you
got to stop that [__] you know what I
mean like because it doesn't look good
I'm like oh no it's a weird one when
you're in the middle of a fight are you
like what's the intent there to take to
knock him out or to submit him or is it
all moment to moment or round around I
mean are there certain Pockets that
you're going for man you'll you always
want to get a finish you're always going
to want to get a finish uh but you know
it's just
yeah you've got to fight the fights in
front of you as well you can't like uh
if you look at your your Elite Fighters
your best fighters and things like that
they're usually going to be very
defensively sound as well if that makes
sense yeah you've got to you've got to
look after yourself at the same time
while I was I'm I found a decent balance
where I'm
you know I'm still going for it like you
see me definitely taking a lot of risk
but still trying to take as minimal
damage while I do that so people can
relate to that people are still you know
excited from from the fights and things
though but it's
it's a it is a tricky one but you're
always looking for a finish but at the
same time you still need to fight the
right fight you need to fight smart you
need a you know it's it's just a yeah
it's a weird one yeah yeah sorry man I
had mine
no worries you take every opportunity
that you can get yeah exactly right yeah
so that's uh when you're on top you're
gonna look for the Finish but again you
want to maintain uh control yeah uh when
you're Landing you want to land you want
to if you rock them you want to
capitalize on that uh you know but at
the same time
if I just go looking for that and only
that that's when I'm going to get caught
and you know you need to find a perfect
balance of where you can still touch
them and not really get touched it's
it's so frustrating how often we see
a fader Rock their opponent and then
clench up yeah when they've got them
hurt they're just clinching up and
giving them time to recover yeah yeah
exactly right it does happen like
sometimes uh it could be them landing
and not knowing that they rocked them
and they're just clinched because that's
just second nature for them that's just
Instinct Forum uh but then uh yeah or
grab a hold of them take advantage of
them being hurt grab a hold I'm hoping
to get them down like I I don't know
what it is well with the Islam ones so I
landed so I knew it landed and then
he was good enough to know again four
four guys that have been wrestling and
and uh you know his whole life he's been
fighting his whole life so he could he
was like Still Rock but he's still
looking for a leg it's just instinct no
matter how uh rocked you got him he's
gonna grab a leg and still clinch and he
doesn't even have to be all there to for
his muscle memory to do what it needs to
do right so you could see that I rocked
him I was gonna go down he's already
looking for a leg while he's just
reaching out and I've like had to sprawl
and I've ended up in his garden then
he's just grabbed the hold of me and I
had to try and find myself out of there
where it would have looked like come on
hit him here he was like obviously I
want to hit him but he's done a good
enough job to to just survive survive
survive and then I find find my way out
and that's when I started raining down
bombs but he did a good he did a good
enough job to not let me capitalize too
much on on rocking him does he let you
not capitalize on him because he's a
little bit more well hydrated than you
are during the fight
you looked pretty hydrated
I mean if you're not hydrated are you
still thinking that clearly or does that
oh man look at the thing is you know
you've got it down down to a side so you
know he does a big big cut and you could
you can see like I've seen him even when
he was in Abu Dhabi and I was doing the
back I had to be backup fighter uh I
remember just seeing him uh backstage
before he walked out he's just out of it
and you're just like man like what these
guys do to themselves don't get me wrong
I cut a fair bit when I get to
featherweight but I never look like that
and uh and then the same thing like you
just seem coming in it's just like that
and but I mean you still got the the 24
hours or more you've got like the whole
day to recover you can still do it but I
mean obviously yeah you can hydrate in
many ways but well yeah
a reference to the
eye is it confirmed that there was an
illegal IV situation it seems that it's
confirmed well I'm just uh staying right
out of it like this is something that
I'm like you know okay yeah so sorry
about like that's all right
do you know is it uh is it true that Dan
hooker is being punished for I saw that
headline but I don't know if it's true
yeah I think what he means is
not punishers in
anything other than like he's trying to
say like you know now they're gonna you
know they'll probably for me saying
stuff like that they're probably gonna
come after me wherever it is no no oh
yeah maybe you mentioned that but he's
probably talking about you know all of
you know because I'm doing stuff like
that and and questioning things right
right next minute
usaid is going to be testing him every
morning you know for the next uh six
weeks or you know I think that's what he
was trying to say okay uh yeah like I'm
not punished as in right yeah because
again I I I'm trying to stay uh right
out of it but I mean we'll keep you up
yeah yeah but I mean there's a
there's stuff there after the fight are
you like uh after all the cameras are
done are you shooting Islam attacks like
hey good fight do you guys ever keep in
touch you were Max you or anybody are
you like saying like give them a call
like dude that was crazy are you kind of
just after the fight's over work's done
and you go home it does happen you'll be
surprised that or it didn't happen uh
with this this fight like you know
usually a couple days later after the
fight like I went straight uh backstage
and was like you know I always shake
hands with them I always go and uh
um you know we you know you're still
sharing a massive moment with these guys
right like this history we're making so
it's something that uh you know I'll
always uh
be you know I want to probably share
that moment so even afterwards I'd be
like oh you know well done you know we
put on a show for everyone you know
again making history so it's something
that uh I definitely
we'll try and embrace their moments but
I mean uh usually we will I will talk to
them but now there's uh you know some
words are still being said here and
there so I don't know if it's going to
be as friendly as uh some other guys
right I mean
I remember had like real vitriol or you
know particularly nasty trash talk like
you've always been you know pretty uh
like honorable and and uh positive about
your promotion yeah exactly that's uh
that's just who I am right and there's
something I'm proud of as well no I know
what is the entertainment business but
the beauty of it is uh we can entertain
with these you know what I mean in the
Octagon uh you know so it's
I get it I get like another but I mean
that everyone thinks that's the only way
to promote yourself but I mean there's
still many ways in many ways I'm I'm
happy with where I've got myself uh and
to be myself through that whole process
for sure so I'm very happy with that
very proud of that I saw your Countryman
Robert Whittaker talking about how he
feels his lack of salacious track Trash
Talk has prevented him from getting big
fights and uh
I I wonder because it's not always
necessary that's right trash talk is not
necessary to be successful as a fighter
but what is absolutely necessary for
success in fighting and I would argue
anything else is taking care of your
health and specifically your diet by
filling in the gaps with ag1 from
athletic greens why because ag1 is the
most comprehensive convenient
nutritional supplement there is it's
loaded with 75 different vitamins
minerals Whole Foods sourced superfoods
probiotics adaptogens and it is
absolutely delicious I'm telling you you
start off your day with a pint of water
to hydrate yourself and in that pint of
water you put a scoop or a packet of ag1
from athletic greens and the gaps in
your diet are filled for the day your
gut health is improved your cognitive
ability is improved and did I mention it
is absolutely delicious telling you this
is the best healthiest stuff for you and
if you go to athletic greens.com
Stevo they will throw in five
completely free
convenient comprehensive travel packs of
ag-1 plus an entire year's supply of
immune boosting vitamin D with your
first purchase that is if you go to
athleticgreens.com
Stevo jump on that deal right now and be
successful in your life now let's get
back to it yeah well look uh you're
right
you know it's it it definitely uh Canada
you've seen all the time you see guys
get a couple of Knockouts obviously you
need the Knockouts but that trash talk
as well it can sure it can the hype can
go up real quick yeah Fast Track you to
things and and that's uh that's that's
legit you know and like that's uh no lie
we see it happen all the time and yeah
you get a lot of good opportunities from
it you know what I mean and uh the
money's gonna be good and all that's
going to Fast Track you but but at the
same time some people are just that's
who they are anyway so it works well and
then you get guys that are going to be
just put on a shower and all that and
you can you can see some of them and
again like his name's always going to
come up I've said some things but I mean
I don't want to have a bad blood with
the guy but you see like someone like
Colby Covington who he knows he he knows
he plays that sort of role I'm gonna
play it you know what I mean which is
you know it's it's weed it's a weed sort
of thing to do so for me I just couldn't
do that she was on his way out of the
UFC because his fights were deemed so
boring with all the wrestling uh I read
the style of wrestling I should say and
his Trash Talk saved his career so power
Zoom so there you go so that and then
you you look so as much as people want
to hate it and here I am saying that
like I couldn't do it
but you'll be lying to yourself if you
didn't think that benefited him it put
him in a much better position so like I
can say what I want people can say
whatever they want at the end of the day
he's way breaking up probably a lot more
money than he would have if he didn't do
it big time and at the end of the day
even if he isn't that type of guy the
people who he cares about or care about
him know exactly who he is if everyone
else thinks he's a piece of [__] or
whatever who cares my family know what
I'm all about so right you can't hate on
that so and that's why I've always
sometimes I get it it's just not me
that's that's what I'm trying to say not
only do I not hate on it I mean
I've been very candid to say that I am
so invested that I enjoy disliking Colby
Covington so much that I'm more excited
for his fights than anybody yeah and and
I just can't stand the guy
you know but um yeah go ahead yeah well
that's like a marketing sort of a tool
like you hear it a lot of the time where
people want to people will pay to watch
to watch him lose yeah so like you know
I mean that bad blood that happens like
oh no is this guy gonna you know get get
him in like we've had guys uh even
Mayweather you know you're Mayweather
still you know people are still waiting
to see him before you know what I mean
but uh it's probably not going to happen
with someone like Mayweather but like a
lot of people uh made a a career off
that and like even in Australia we've
had guys that literally some they
actually I've been told very nice guys
uh Anthony mundine but he would play the
villain and you'd make probably one of
the most uh amounts of money in
Australian boxing because that's the you
know people in there to watch that and
so again you gotta you gotta understand
that it's entertainment it is yeah so
with the Islam Islam fight
up to that point the rule was that if
you beat somebody who's ranked higher
than you then you take their spot
like a pound for pound especially and
then Islam beat you but you kept the
number one pound-for-pound spot yeah and
and that's I don't think there's a
person in the world that disagrees with
that yeah you know like you weren't
fighting in your weight class you came
up a lot of bigger guys so you kept
number one pound per pound can you
explain what pound for pounds okay let's
let's get into that so when you say uh
in pound for pound you take someone you
majority of the time you will take take
it but at the end of the day that's
always going to be a
different to an actual uh like a
ranking like a featherweight ranking
right for featherweight ranking you beat
someone you take their spot you just
beat the guy that makes makes sense we
pound for pound that has a lot more than
just
just your ranking in that division so
it's gonna it's gonna come down to skill
power for pound like we understand that
so if you we were all the same size yeah
with the same skill so everything was
even playing Phil except for the skill
like you had your skill and uh whatever
it was but we're all the same size like
who would sort of win so say imagine me
in a heavyweights body with uh the
heavyweight strength and all that type
of stuff you know what I mean like so
that like you know what would I do to
these heavyweights you know that's how
people would uh look at it type thing so
it's a weird one it's obviously that's
why a lot of people just can't stand the
power for pound rankings but everyone
loves talking about it it's a big deal
I'll be honest with you being a champion
was great being pound for pound
uh number one which uh Jon Jones just
took that for oh he did I didn't Google
I don't think we've all of them I don't
think we've all of them but I mean I
think with the UFC yes I
I was dying to know that and I and I
resisted
yeah
I'm glad Jon Jones won I'm impressed by
his victory but I just don't think we
saw enough in that fight to go ahead and
compound for pound number one yeah but I
mean you're gonna
I guess it's gonna have to do with he he
actually said it said it really well
where it goes by what you've done lately
as well right it's going to go with that
you know you you might have done a whole
heap four years ago that's got nothing
to do with now you are not powerful we
don't know what you're doing right now
so that's always still going to come
into play though
you know again you're right it was just
that one but what he did moving up he at
least he moved up and showed that the
powerful pound comes into play you know
uh the body of work that we've done in
the last three years obviously a lot of
people are going to be look what Alex
has done in the last three years and you
can get that but at the same time look
at what John Jones has done as well so
can I really argue that when you look at
you he's going to be one of the greatest
of all times so for him to take that as
like hey you know what do you do what do
you think about his fight I mean were
you just like what the [__] I expected
uh him to Oh I thought he should wrestle
I I thought if he was to grab a hold him
I think he's going to have do really
well if he uses all these tools I think
his biggest the biggest problem for him
would be with these heavyweights landing
on him but when it comes to wrestling I
think he's going to outdo all of all the
heavy weights even your steep base I
think uh because Jon Jones wrestling is
incredible like you know and that's a
people are really
I don't think it's underestimate I think
people know but I mean look what even uh
DC was taking DC down you know what I
mean so it's pretty crazy uh to see uh
what he's capable of but I didn't expect
him to be so aggressive with the
wrestling that surprised me so because
uh we chatted to him in the lead up to
that that fight and he was uh you know
saying that he's seen holes in the stand
up and I'm like is he really going to
try and uh exploit that or is he gonna
do what he should do and go there but it
was always he just got right in there as
soon as he found that right time to
clinch and even when he went down and
shot he made sure he was sticking he's
like I ain't giving this guy a chance
which I thought was a very clever and if
I knew that he was going to be in them
positions I would have expected a finish
I just didn't think he would be that
aggressive uh to look for a finisher to
look for the control I thought he might
like play play try and clinch grab a
hold and then look for a trip or work
him on the cage and maybe look for a
takedown from there
um so yeah it was a it was still a
little bit different to what I expected
just purely because I didn't expect him
to be so aggressive with wrestling right
give him pound for pound number one that
is kind of like me saying we should
punish him for making it look so easy
so maybe he does deserve it yeah but uh
actually as I said I talked to John Jazz
we talked to him uh on uh UFC fight week
with Robert Whittaker we're having a
chat to him and like that question come
up where uh they asked if they're like
you know if you win do you think your
number one power for power while I was
sitting right there and he goes look it
goes by and that's when he touched on me
being active and what I've done look
what I've done that my body of work so
right now I was like because I'm not
chasing power for pound I'm trading I'm
chasing the greatest of all time and
things are obviously that's what I'm
chasing but
um look at the body of work he's done
because he's been fine I've still got a
couple more years to do that so I'm
going to keep uh pushing for that but
right now you know powerful pound was uh
where I was at which is a great
accomplishment and I I still look to to
get that back anyway so it motivates me
motivates me to be like all right I want
to get back in there whether jira rig is
in July bang and then do that rematch
with Islam and you know and then
obviously like I said 2023 is going to
be a a massive view for me so even
though uh the start of the Year wasn't
exactly how he wanted it again we talked
about the stock still Rising it's making
a bigger rematch Avon still wants to see
that and then getting another title
fight and then getting the the
lightweight title later in the year like
what a way to end a massive year so
that's that's what that's my plans for
this year did they already have a line
for the you're afraid against Yayo
Rodriguez a line yeah I'm not sure no I
don't think so what's not locked in like
we haven't even uh yeah we have a lot to
lock that in at all I gotta believe that
you're just a humongous favorite in that
well you
is he still dangerous you know me 100
he's still a very very dangerous uh
opponent and uh that's the view that's
the thing with me like I can go into
this fight I don't care how big of a
favorite I am I'm never gonna go
underprepared yeah I think you're going
to get a lot of people that that might
get to them they might think like you
know they might pull back it's just not
who I am I'm Gonna Give It All I'm gonna
see the risk I'm gonna see the dangers
and I'm going to prepare to make sure
he don't get me with these dangers you
know make sure that don't happen and not
just that I'm going to prepare for the
worst just in case he gets me to deep
Waters do I think he can get me to dig
Waters I think he can definitely hurt me
the chance of him getting me into deep
Waters and getting me tired and and
really dominating me and making me
really go for adversity through the
whole fight I don't think that's without
being disrespectful I don't think that's
a way but I'm gonna prepare for that
anyway that's just how I how I mean look
at the co-main when you when it was she
was plus a thousand
because this is fascinating the greatest
thing
the UFC world uh two questions number
one what if you think what do you think
of the inspection Zone where they're
putting the Vaseline they're checking
your cup you know if in the inspection
Zone you were standing on a scale so
that everybody could know the how much
weight has come back on since the
official weigh-in I think it would just
be really interesting personally if you
knew how much the fighter weighed as
they stepped into the Octagon for the
fight that'd be that'd be I think
that'll be yeah a lot of people would be
interested in knowing that but with that
we actually do get weighed
yeah so we go there I don't know if they
actually they don't they don't make that
public oh they don't I know they I know
they've I swear they've done it before
maybe they haven't done it before oh
yeah because I remember
uh flat Island I went there and they did
that and I remember being
extra heavy because there's a a big wake
up because it was short notice and
things like that
and I remember being heavy like I ended
up getting to 77 so uh you're weighing
at or what's that that's that's 170. so
it was 145. yeah and I ended up weighing
170 and I was like and you could see it
I looked very very yeah probably more
because the fighter Island they give you
so much time but then after that one it
made me realize I don't want to be that
heavy so I've actually made sure I was
well under that so either when I get to
when I find it featherweight I'm always
making sure I sit around I couldn't tell
you in pounds what it is but yeah I
usually make sure I'm around 74
kilograms which I could get to 77 I
could get to 76. uh but I I don't like
that so I always make sure I'm there
because that's where I move best that's
where I'm sharpest and I'm just as
strong what are you now what am I now I
don't think about it yeah I reckon I'll
be 170 170 yeah I reckon so when I yeah
170 right
um it the uh the the problem with the
you know disclosing a Fighter's weight
at the time of the actual fight I I
understand to be that they uh it draws
too much attention to weight cutting you
know like weight cutting's a little bit
controversial and yeah yeah they don't
wanna they don't want to draw too much
attention to that but they do know the
the fighters weights and um then my
second question was
I don't think anybody wants to see open
scoring you know when uh when we know
what the judges scorecards read at the
end of each round
um but what I love is to get the live
odds as the fight progresses and and uh
when we were at Dana White's house
I I said what do you think about like
the beginning of every round two every
round three like every like uh
subsequent round started with the live
odds and uh and Dana pulls out his phone
he sends a voice message and say hey
Stevo's got a request he wants the the
live odds so so literally for the rest
of that card it came on and uh so we saw
the live ons for every uh every round
with you in Islam well it's funny to say
because I remember seeing them because I
was gonna go I'm pretty sure they did
that and you're like oh yeah because of
you yeah so there you go and Dana said
you're not wrong I I
like and uh he called it
it's Steve Oz there you go but then uh
since then they haven't been doing it
all the time no like I said they didn't
do it they didn't do the last event but
you did shoot him a text I shot I shot
Dana a text during the uh Valentina
Alexa Grosso fight right at the
beginning because it was like uh
Valentina started minus 850 favorite and
uh and Alexa grazia looked pretty good
so I texted Dana uh live odds please
round number two we got the live odds
and where I thought Alexa Grosso had
looked good uh on the second round
Valentina when
of minus 1 000 favorite no okay the
Valentine became an even bigger favorite
and uh I I understood at that point why
maybe they wouldn't want to you know if
the discrepancy is going to get bigger
and bigger than the fight potentially
becomes less interesting so maybe they
don't want to always give the live odds
but thank God they did in that case
because the odds got the the Gap got
even bigger and as of minus one thousand
who doesn't love to know the odds and
even better who doesn't love to increase
their own odds of success in their
personal and business life that's right
and I've got the way to do it it's
called ship station this is for anybody
who has an e-commerce operation whether
they're selling merchandise to fans on
Amazon or Etsy or their own website
doesn't matter if you're not selling
merch and goods to your fans online then
you are blowing it and if you are then
you gotta be using ships station because
it is one easily integrated interface
which combines every Outlet of selling
with every Outlet of shipping you got
the United States Post Office you got
UPS you get your FedEx it's all boiled
into one easy to use interface and they
reserve the best shipping rates which
are normally only for Fortune 500
companies I'm telling you this is the
secret to my online e-commerce success
because every order comes just printed
out with a label which gets slapped on
the box and into the box might go a
Stevo and Johnny Knoxville skateboard I
mean that's how it works it's easy and
if you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo then you're going to get an entire
two months of hassle free free ship
Station Service I'm telling you you
cannot pass this up it's an absolute
guaranteed satisfaction situation so go
to shipstation.com and use the promo
code Stevo and makeshift happen yeah
dude now let's get back to it
but it's uh with the open scoring I
think I think your Youth and L on the
head too like right it's
that adds to it right people wanted to
know what's going on right with a
decision so like you know people like
you know everyone's on their seat like
what happened it takes away you know
what I mean yeah and when a fighter
knows they're up two rounds in a
three-round fight they're they're gonna
coast and make it boring yeah so they're
gonna do I guess you're gonna get the
other guy who knows their behind us I
need to go for the finish right so they
might do that but at the same time
you're right they're going to try and
play it safe everyone knows it ruins the
the suspenser but if you want light on
the fact that like some of these judges
are like like how the F like if you're
focusing on open scoring then that would
mean that you would know who like the
casuals don't know who the refs are or
the who the judges are so wouldn't it
bring more to light like some of these
people that are just so [__]
completely wrong about some of their
scoring I mean that that would be the
case
after the fight
the fight cards are made public every
time you're gonna know which judge was
out of there some of them definitely get
uh get called out on it you see it a few
times yeah but I don't really know their
names but after summer I was like oh
this idiot again did this score or like
you're like oh there you go so they do
get
I mean it is a tough job like you know I
mean a lot of it's you know we're
obviously going to be easy to to
criticize but I mean it must be a tough
job even the ref and all that like while
it's all happening uh you got the crowd
going nuts and all that you know all of
it and then the scoring criteria cost
criteria criteria sorry sort of changes
here and there and then
you know it's a it's it's weird because
they say damage first and significant
strikes and then you've got to weigh in
control time why that's happening when
they tell you not it's just yeah because
for me because Islam had you down but
you were punching them the whole time so
like who wins that so it's a if that's a
trigger so for me and I'm I'm I'm going
to be real with it like for me he was in
a controlled position
so I'm going to always give that to to
the person controller I think it could
be up to the ref
maybe there's new rules where if these
guys are looking at just like if they
are stalling maybe the ref needs to do
something I don't care how dominant the
position is if you are just trying to
survive and hang on and it's clear like
you're not trying to go for punches
you're not trying to go for submissions
you were just trying to wake the round
out obviously the crowd don't want to
see that right and uh and at the end of
the day
is that really winning it's like you've
secured a position good on you yes so
that's why that's going to be worth
something but if you are not trying to
improve your position or do something
the ref's going to have to be like come
on let's at least do something you're in
a dominant position at least try and
capitalize if not I'm going to stand you
up so I I look at that as more of
something that the ref could do rather
than the judges scoring it so for me
even though I was doing more at the end
of the day I was in a position where
obviously I wanted to get to get out of
that you know I was in a position so I
don't think
it's weird
I didn't win Islam the fight what won
him to fight was his striking yeah yeah
we might like he's definitely a surprise
movie Striker it's like in Garner's
Surprises with his wrestling against God
and then Islam surprises has been
striking against you
so I knew he's got a good oil and you're
going in there he had a good eye uh I
knew his patient which
it's a tricky one for me if I wanted to
I had to make the a lot of the first
moves I had to do like a initiate most
of what was happening because he's very
patient uh he even says that uh heavier
always says Be The Matador that's with
something that you always hear them
talking about is it be the matadors in
react yeah we're all like yes I'd bring
them to you like yeah and then wait for
them wait for him and then like you know
so like let them come crazy at you and
then find their times to counter or
shoot which is which is good but at the
same time if I I'm aware of that
do I sit back and just try and pick
shots and be safe and then we don't give
the fans a fight they want I could still
lose
so it was a tricky one for me so I knew
he was waiting and being patient and
waiting to count on me and shoot but it
was a situation where I could try and
deal with that a different way but
there's still a good chance of me losing
I won't be able to Tire him out I won't
be able to put the pressure on him and
if if I fight a different fight so for
me
so that surprised how patient he was and
I expect him to in them them times to
probably try and shoot more not not
throw counters as much so again credit
to him for for having the eye again like
as I said I always knew he had a good
eye but uh he still surprised me with
somebody I thought the shots the timing
was going to be better with the shots
not the strikes which uh was uh was cool
so obviously towards the end I started
getting reads and I you know I wish I
could do that fight again right now
because I could do stuff but I mean
that's that's the game
that reminded me of the Darren Elkins
fight Darren the damage Elkins uh and
and what was your injury when you fought
so a tall tall my intercostal muscle so
it's like uh so yeah so it's pretty much
you know you break a rib or you tear
your rib cartilage it's or tear your
muscle it's like a
pretty much all the same sort of uh
symptoms like you you can't move like
I'll put it this way I and I did that
like I think two days before the fight
so uh you you literally cannot move like
tall like a when I say tour is a proper
tear yeah you know it wasn't like a
little a small tear was a like ripped
muscle right there so he was
so painful I couldn't believe it like I
remember sitting there like that that
wouldn't happen like we had people in
the room also the fighters uh warm-up
area and we had other Fighters there and
I didn't want anyone knowing so I'm like
trying to like get to the side like
crawl over there and like try and be
quiet and then they're like oh you know
my coaches are like oh if you uh if you
could still breathe it's not hurting or
you'll be right I'm like
don't worry it's [__] hurting like
you know what I mean I didn't want to
say loud oh God it is just relax I like
it this isn't good so I end up uh going
back we end up getting the UFC doctor to
have a chance he's like yeah you've
turned that in of course from my muscle
like and I've asked you know what do
people fight he goes yeah like people
some people will fight some people will
pull out but we've never had a fighter
have it this close to a fight so that's
what he said to me because usually two
three weeks out people either pulling
out from the fight or maybe they take it
on but he goes we haven't had someone do
it probably this close and I'm like oh
because if you sit there goes yeah we
have been we haven't I'm like oh that's
good but we haven't had anyone this
close I was like [__] so I started I'm
like oh I need a fight because this was
back when I needed the money and my care
had a big camp and I was like I had no
option I had to fight he goes I can get
you on these uh anti-inflammatories
which we're allowed to take
uh those strong ones and I can by the
time you fight we can maybe half the
pain at the time I'm like half the pain
is not enough like I couldn't I couldn't
warm up I couldn't even do anything for
the the next couple of days I remember
warming up
five day like so warming up backstage
before the fight I couldn't even throw
my right hand yet so I could only throw
a jab so I could throw my jab because I
could keep this here but I could not
twist my body yet and I'm like all right
well we're gonna have to wait till
adrenaline kicks in and then I can start
to use that so it was a pretty it was
definitely a crazy process another funny
story with that with these uh
uh anti-inflammatories they were like
really strong anti-inflammatories
my coach and manager end up getting them
because uh the yeah the UFC doctor said
yeah get this one you're allowed to take
it it's all good and uh they're strong
and that should help sweet so they went
and got him and I was like taking them
and the amount I'm taking is a fair bit
because we had to try and do the best we
can and I remember I was just like
groggy pass and now falling asleep all
day I'm like what's going on here and
I'm saying that to him are you sure
these aren't like nighttime ones or
something like that and they're like and
they're like no no it's not and then we
end up finding out they gave me
um the nighttime ones which they make
you really drowsy and all that and again
I'm like pretty much overdosing on these
things that's how much I had to take and
I was just on the nod all day like the
whole time and then like oh mate was it
was the worst of like something
something's not right so then they ended
up getting me the right ones it was
always a bit better but that was strong
stronger and you could just get them
over the counter in America so like over
here you need a prescription for
everything but over there I don't know
if it's changed but like literally you
could just go and get like a really
strong stuff like yeah just go in there
and just get them off the bench you know
um and certain when you were telling the
story about you know getting injured
before the fight like I I started
thinking oh man like as a fan it was so
disappointing when TJ dillashot fought
and he had not disclosed to the UFC that
he had that issue with his shoulder and
it really uh it it comforted me and made
me uh just respect a lot that you went
straight to tell the UFC that you had
that concern yeah yeah well that's I
wanted to know what's I was always going
to fight but I was like what's the best
option for me can I am I allowed to uh
get a cortisone shot
and things like you know I wanted to
know the process I have the cortisone
shot that can help but then like on you
could do that but the commission's
probably going to pull you from the
fight so we can't do the cortisone shot
um but we can do this and then uh you
can fight it's like oh well I've got no
option so I'm just doing that yeah I
mean like that's just that's just the
game especially
you know now if you're risking losing
the building you don't feel like you can
perform 100 do you pull out you know you
go into every fight You're Gonna Go
injured and things like that but I mean
you can you can get through you know
some things suck but I mean you can you
can get through it sometimes yeah that
was your worst injury going into a fight
uh where's the at most people yeah I
would say so pain wise because I feel
like I said I couldn't even I still
couldn't even
breathe properly I couldn't get a big
like that or like kill yeah like I was
getting out in and out of bed like I
literally would have to game plan to get
out of the bed like I couldn't like
because I was water I had to get out of
bed and I was like I remember sitting
there like trying to get out of bed and
then I would like I'd end up crying
because I'm like
you know I don't think I'm going to be
able to fight this before I seen the
doctor and like you know I was crying I
couldn't even cry because it's hurting
me too much so you know I mean that's
just that much pain I was like what am I
gonna do you know what I mean so anxiety
through the roof but uh we've got it
done you you brought up sorry were you
now something I I
I just wanted to ask about that uh Brian
Ortega submission that was the craziest
thing I've ever seen I think like like
how did you not tap
Alexander volkanovsky's will to go on is
unbelievable my will to go on sometimes
could use a little bit of help and that
is why I proudly use Bluetooth tablets
why because they have the same active
ingredient as both Viagra and Cialis
except they only cost a fraction of the
price and get this The Listener of the
Wild Ride podcast have the opportunity
to get an entire month's supply of
Bluetooth tablets which I might say are
now more delicious than ever it's like
eating candy it's great and you can get
this entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets completely for free only pay
five bucks for shipping if you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo even better is that when you're at
Bluetooth dot com you can very easily
easily conveniently consult with their
online medical provider to take care of
the prescription and boom that entire
month's supply of Bluetooth tablets is
on the way and all you pay is five bucks
for shipping and if you're wondering hmm
our Bluetooth tablet's a lot of fun let
me assure you there are a ton of fun man
they give me that will to go on and that
is a valuable thing so bluetooth.com
with the promo code Stevo jump on it and
have fun let's get back to it
well tapping was it I guess tapping was
never an option but then you go how did
you go to sleep at the same time because
it was deep it was really deep and I've
talked about it a fair bit and I always
mentioned the dimming of the lights so
it was getting close close enough where
like everything was starting to go black
and I was like on on over like well you
know like just keep going keep going but
there was never in my mind ever uh not
even a thought where I was like I might
have to tap he was like oh no this ain't
good luck keep pushing on the hip like I
was just what do I do and like oh no
this isn't good but yeah it was never an
option to tap it was always like keep
doing what you're doing or go or die you
know what I mean like that was my two
options like you go to sleep maybe not
die or um or get out you know what I
mean and I just kept doing what I did
even though so there's a lot of
like when you talk about the mental side
of that sort of uh situation
I got into that that submission I'm like
well how do I get here and then it's
there and I'm like I'm going to do this
doing what I thought was right and it
was right but he applied it so good and
that's his move that it was still not
working so I did everything you should
do and could do in that situation and it
still wasn't enough and I'm still going
out then I had to tell myself well
I'm just going to keep going hopefully
he gases before I go to sleep or you
know what I mean like that's that's my
only two options because tapping was
never an option so I kept going and then
I felt him uh that the the group sort of
released that little bit and I started
getting these hips out a little bit
higher and higher and then the lights
started coming back and instantly even
in that that moment where I still can't
breathe uh like uh obviously the the
blood and oxygen must be come to the
brain because the lights are coming back
and I haven't I haven't went to sleep
yet but even in that moment where I'm
still obviously hurting and struggling
to breathe but I seen felt weakness
that's me he's guessed the arm's already
like getting out of there just the
lights are coming he's gassing his gas
and get on top and fix him up you know
what I mean like that was my that was my
mindset in that moment while I was still
like struggling to breathe so I was like
try to scramble up and then as soon as I
got up I've just went nuts and then put
myself in another big submission
obviously he's another his other uh
go-to movie in the Triangle so it was a
crazy sequence but you're right man like
well that was a massive moment and one
that probably will be talked about
forever it was the most Savage moment
where did you I was going to ask about
like adrenaline dumps during a fight how
do you prepare for that or what what
does that look like or does it happen at
the same time every fight does it
sometimes happen after the fights I mean
because it's a lot of build up for the
main event I mean and then have you
asked if you guys asked of athletes or
other Fighters about this no
I'm I think you might be asking the
wrong person because I feel like I don't
get that okay
um and that's why but I mean
DC Talk yeah and he was talking about
the the Jon Jones fight and he was like
there's a lot of things you don't take
into consideration and that's the
adrenaline dump yeah uh of a main event
yeah and I was thinking about that and I
just said I never thought about that
like your body must just kind of like
gas out during a fight like what is that
I just don't even know what that looks
like so for me
this is where I feel like uh this
Separates Me from from a lot of the
people when it comes to nerves and
things like that I don't really get uh
like that I don't get nervous I'm very
calm and very composed I don't get even
when I try and I try and build myself up
usually just so I can get that energy I
need to go in there you've seen me do
that in the last few fights where I work
the crowd and you see me being a little
cheeky and noctagon that's just to Hype
myself up because
I've went always went into fights all
right crowds and that all right keep
yourself you know calm down calm down I
did that and I got myself way too calm
so now I'm like I need the energy yeah
that's weird I'm Different what's your
heart rate then at that point I'd love
to see my heart rate obviously it's not
going to be because I can get down to
like you know even when I really feel
like down to like 35s and stuff like
that yeah yeah like resting uh so I can
get really really low uh but
in that moment obviously it's never
going to be that low but I'd love to see
what most people are to me because I'm
pretty chill in there man I really am
and that's why I feel like I I really uh
I I am different in that in that sense
so that's when you ask about the nervous
and adrenaline dump I'd love to know
what other people's thoughts are for
them to really break it down so I can
see how I'm different because I don't
get any of that I really don't even like
walking out your songs playing you're
not nervous I'm not nervous I'm thinking
of each step all right what do I do now
oh yeah work The Crowd Oh you give this
guy a handshake you know I'm I'm just
going there and then even when I'm in
there
like Islam's across there I'm sitting
there and like all right
he's gonna look for this and I'm like
talking to myself we've got to watch out
for this
telling myself like because sometimes
you're going to have maybe doubts in
your head but I won't get nervous right
now I might have not doubt so you're
gonna have a list of these voices in
your head like oh what if this happens
what if that happens but when it comes
fight time I'm in there as I go Nana
[__] that I'm gonna get this I'm gonna
do that and you know I I have them
conversations in my head where I'm just
like
I need to do this I need to do that fire
yourself up talk to your corner it's
weird it's a it's just I just feel like
I'm Different to most people in that
situation is that just in the UFC or
like were you nervous when you proposed
your wife or were you nervous like yeah
you know I get more nervous watching
teammates a lot of people say this as
well though um I get more nervous
watching teammates fighting when I'm
cornering and stuff like that because
I'm not in control I'm not trying to be
in control so that's a lot harder for me
but yeah I could be fighting for
Champion against a guy who's
a red hot favorite you know there was a
never had a chance you know obviously in
my last fight and still just be as chill
as I am talking to you guys right now
yeah I mean I just had this thought you
know you said that you're stuck Rose
after that it's 100 right I think Islam
stock
declined after that you know you got
Ariel hawani you know I think I saw
Ariel saying uh Islam is not khabib 2.0
and I couldn't help but Wonder just now
if Islam stock fell so much that that
has something to do with khabib now
stepping away from coaching
so we'll look
such a
that's that's the first thing maybe
that's what it is it's a flight game as
well right so he was expected to win and
all you know and
I always was going out there and what
happened like I was planning on doing
even better than what happened you got
to remember that a lot of people didn't
expect that but obviously that's what
I'm doing and people don't know me and I
try and I think I'm starting to prove
that I'm Different to to people as well
you know I'm a you know when it comes to
adversity they never die attitude like
the mindset
in preparation all that like you know
you you see the work I've done and I I'm
the proof is in the pudding right and
so you you are right because they're
looking at that as like oh the
featherweight did this to him and
there's no way he's doing that but don't
be surprised if he goes back and has a
fight in lightweight and just walk
straight through them sure and then
people are going to be like they could
probably just say oh you just had off
night or like that they're probably
never gonna even though people are still
giving me a lot of credit for what
happened
but which I'm I'm glad because I believe
that's what it was I don't think it was
anything else but me preparing properly
and the fighter I am and I tried telling
people before the fight that this is
this is why it's going to be a tough
fight for Islam trust me you're like you
know I mean let's cause I'm the guy I'm
that type of guy that can go and be put
in this position and and take it you
know and I tried telling people that and
obviously a lot of people didn't believe
me but
yeah so it's it's a tricky one a lot of
people are going to be harder on him
in that situation because everyone's
like that dagestani wrestling you know
and all that and I'm trying to go yeah
if you prepare properly like I know what
he does well I'm preparing for that I'm
the I've got the right style to deal
with that I'm gonna show you this but uh
a lot of people didn't believe it so
then uh you've got some people like well
you know he was right then you've got
other people like going ah Islam is in
uh khabib is no way it's two point you
know what I mean like so it's a it's a
it's harsh that's the dynamic there's a
little bit of a win-win for you and a
lose-lose for him exactly that's what
was always going to be for him you know
he could have gone there and you know
say if he did just mop the floor with me
right he definitely gets that pound for
pound number one spot uh he probably
expected to be an easy fight so he
didn't look at it as much risk at all
but I mean I'm joking but he doesn't
realize how much of risk he sees because
I'm the smaller guy and I'm telling you
I'm going to give you a fight it felt
like it was khabib's idea right like did
he force him into it yeah it felt like
it was khabib's ideas
and then go straight to take the number
one spot and maybe he didn't get the
number one spot and khabib was just like
laughs
man you gotta I guess you gotta you
gotta feel for him but I mean when it
comes to pound for pound I I get it I
just didn't think
they would
do it how it's pretty much meant to
that's how like you know that they
literally that's probably the only time
I've ever seen them really prove
what power for pound is all about by
doing that so you went into a fight the
smaller guy
uh you know the much smaller one you
know from a smaller division went up a
supposedly a really bad matchup
uh stylistically and all that type of
stuff and then
some people say you won or whatever it
is let's just say it was even or yeah
whatever however you look at it
can you really say that guy is a better
fighter right you know what I mean so
it's a tricky one that's where
I really thought that they actually
showed that they do at least look into
it a little bit and I'm like oh wow I
didn't expect them to do that like you
know which will surprise me to be honest
you fight at a Welter away MMA like the
Australia Welch
middleweight
she started up middleweight what's that
185 yeah 185 yeah then uh then you'd
fight welterweight yep
um as an amateur
you uh accumulated
under four minutes some fight time
before becoming Pro yeah yeah yeah so
that's uh then that will middleweight
fights as well so those middleweight
fights and uh ended them all like one
more six seconds one was uh I think two
of them were like 30 seconds and then
maybe a two minute something yeah yeah
so it was a
uh yeah yeah so like I went uh Pro with
less than a rounds uh uh experience so
yeah yeah so it's pretty cool when
you're looking at it that way dude it's
epic what made you what made you want to
fight amateur like how'd you know you
wanted to fight why did you fight
I've just always loved it I think you
know it's didn't it start out as like
you just wanted to get fitter for rugby
that's when I started doing it I've
always loved uh martial arts and I've
always looked I wouldn't say I've always
loved fighting it's not like I'm proud
of you I've obviously had your street
fights and whatnot it's not something
proud of it's not something I want to
really talk about but I've always been
known to be able to throw them and uh
it's all my family ever talk about my
uncles and my dad and all that lady
they'll just talk about yeah yeah
because uh you know Macedonian Greek and
oh yeah Warrior blood and all that
that's all they ever talked about so
something that was always I grew up uh
wanting to be a part of really anyway
it's funny actually I've got another
story
um which jackass movie it might have
been the first Jackass movie
so uh
work here at the the movies uh theater
just over here in shellharbour and we
just watched jackass
and then straight after that
um there was just a heap of people
outside and then we all end up getting
into a crazy brawl so it's a again not
enough something I'm proud of you know
but it's just funny that it was we
literally just watched uh jackass we
didn't fight because of that yeah I'm
not trying to say he's like it I'll
hyped us all up it just was a he had a
moment you know being young and silly in
this area
you know getting involved with another
area and then it just end up being all
in I remember
having it with you through a few and
then I remember yes I was a crazy crazy
brawl but that's where it was and I
remember a security guard that was there
uh this was before I did any training
and all that and he luck he pulled me
grabbed me and then look after it all I
calmed down he goes have you ever
thought of taking up some fighting
televisions though you should probably
do some boxing uh so I guess I've always
been known to be able to frog but
there's a little funny story uh one
crazy uh brawl we did again I'm not
proud of that but um it's uh yeah it was
after watching a jackass movie
that he went to school with why were
there Liz Lisa this girl Liz and she
described a time that you were I think
that's always another fight or something
now I'm just gonna look like some
trouble she said you're the biggest
sweetheart yeah
she said you were a sweetheart she
described being uh at like a house party
and they were just the chillest guy and
there was like like like one guy or a
couple guys like really acting up at the
party but being very disrespectful and
she said that you were cool as a
cucumber and you said hey if you keep
this up I'm gonna I'm gonna take care of
you and the guy kept it up and and you
took care of him and that was that yeah
oh man like again like when you're young
it sounded like you got into that fight
for the right reasons yeah I did it the
right way well I mean like because I've
always looked older as well so I've
always been uh so I was this size right
so like right now I'm small but like I
literally stopped going when I was 12.
so when I was 12 I was quite big right
so like I just stopped growing I had the
Beards the beard and everything so
trouble would easily find me I would
always like try and like you know I've
always been like I'll stop it like you
know makes sometimes uh you know cause a
bit of trouble all the time like stop it
guys let's not let's not get involved
with it but being young silly and
um obviously being an area where there
was a lot of fights happening and stuff
like that it would happen but I mean you
could talk to a lot of my friends even
though I did get into a few myths when I
was younger I was never the one that
just would instigate it right I just
obviously stood my ground and didn't
take any [__] and yeah sometimes uh yeah
one thing I hated is bullies if I seen
someone going around and bullying people
and I want to stay out of it but I mean
if they take something too funny I'm
gonna have to step in and you know I'm
not telling people to do that don't do
that but I just cannot stand bullies if
so if there's a bully around me and
they're doing something like that
I'm fighting myself as I'd like to deal
with this person like I can't stand it I
hate it you know what I mean like but
again at the same time you can't just go
around bashing every bully you see
but I just hate that type of stuff sure
um as a rugby player I mean it's it's
well known that that you are over 200
pounds playing rugby just visibly
chunkier
um I'm curious what your
what your endurance was as a record
player Gregory you're running around so
much like having all that weight and
frankly being like kind of fat did your
cardio like have a problem so
that's um that's why I always said like
it's definitely something that uh maybe
that mentality that had even at his
young age and the way I grew up
made me there that uh that guy that's
you know what you see now in the Octagon
right so even though I was heavier but I
was always known for playing the 80
minutes playing the whole game which not
many front rollers did because I was
playing in the position where the
biggest players would would play and
obviously I was a lot heavier even
though I was uh half the size of
everything yeah like five percent yeah
yeah exactly just uh so but I was known
for taking like you know three two three
hit UPS like majority of the sets uh I
was known for just taking doing a lot of
work and just being a little Workhorse I
was known for
for I guess yeah like being a little
Workhorse so even back then even though
I was heavier obviously I wouldn't be as
fit as I was now getting up and down
from defending would tie me a little bit
more trying to get back and forth
because uh and going off the ground and
up the ground like I'd feel it more
defending but I could just run all day
uh and I was known for that I used to
play 18s under 18s I'll play Reserve
grade and then play first grade because
uh back when I was playing uh football
like I just helped the the the club out
I would end up playing all three games
and I'll play 80 minutes of
under 18s play majority of the uh
Reserve grade and then play a heap of
the the first grade as well so and that
was all back to back so you could
imagine uh the minutes and I'll do that
every week so I guess uh when I look
back and talk about and explain that to
you because it's always been there it's
always been there so it's something that
I don't know whether it was just me my
brother bashing each other and wrestling
as kids and whatever it was I don't know
but it was always something that
that was always in me and then uh
luckily I found the the right path
another you know you said I I would
always do two three hit-ups before every
set we're from America what the [__]
does that what does that
means he was just like yeah
yeah
so like there's a set of six uh like
which means instead of six six plays
okay uh it's the NFL it's not like NFL
though you know NFL Downs four downs
yeah four down two you get downs and you
get to stop stop huddle up it's not like
that it is uh ran into a brick wall
pretty much so just run boom get
attacked get a [__] try and quickly play
the ball and you're on part oh pass it
to the yeah so the sixth the six uh
plays would be consecutive would would
be less than a minute
so uh you know so then I would uh you
know have a hit up someone also have a
hit up and then I'd have a head up
straight up so I'd run we'll get tackle
play the ball someone would do that and
then within probably 10 seconds I'm like
you give me another run so I did that
multiple multiple times I would do that
you know I'm not
yeah especially this is something that I
talk about you know some of my my
teammates back and they're gonna hate me
for this but anyway I would uh always
have the the heat UPS which means just
running the ball on our try line so
getting your ball out of our trial line
was very easy to get the ball once you
start getting uh closer to the their
trial line or their goal line what do
you call a goal line End Zone you know
once you get to the end zone everyone
wants a ball I can get a touchdown here
you know what I mean you know I can get
so everyone wants a ball I could barely
even get the ball there but on our end
oh everyone will just let me walk
straight in front of them so I would uh
and I was okay with that I was uh even
back then that mindset had the mentality
I had was
like you know even though it's a team
sport I felt like it was my my duty to
get us the [__] out of our trial line
are we allowed to sweat sorry yeah yeah
yeah so I need to get us I need to get
us out of this I'll be like uh you know
I'll push people out of the way and
they'll be like okay sweet and then I'll
go and give me another hit up and I'll
just get us out of there because I
didn't look at it as or no I need to run
in front of this bloke I'm gonna need to
run into a brick wall against guys that
are twice Society look at ever look at
it that way I looked at it as we need to
get out of here so how do I do that give
me the ball and I'm gonna try and do
that with a quick play the baller I just
look at what needed to be done not at
the actual you know yeah
Steve I have a question for you okay how
jealous are you of volk's ears I love it
I love it yes he's been trying to get
cauliflower here for a long time now
time someone hit it chuckling
better today foreign
[Laughter]
I think I'm past it I think
it just blasted open like how would you
do it there you go I don't know I don't
know where so that's what that's why
that's why you're not going to get the
cauliflower though yeah because it
bursted right open all that fluid right
right so what you would do if you have
you ever got it to blow up
maybe what we did wasn't very effective
but maybe it takes the pound for pound
maybe he's the real one
I'll break down everything you know
later we can maybe get the cameras
rolling after the show
let's talk about it after the dinner
tonight I'm very open to it but what I
want to know
to switch back to rugby you know you're
done with fighting now you're going to
become a professional rugby player again
like how would you approach your
physique what would you want to put on
as much weight as you have before or
would you feel more effective
yeah not a lighter oh it was a lot just
like we were talking about I was heavier
but I mean it was
a lot of uh excess weight like fat and
stuff like that as well you know I'll
definitely rub I don't mind being a bit
here if I was playing football you're
saying yeah yeah playing rugby it will
definitely I'll definitely want to be
heavier because you're going to need
that weight but I mean I wouldn't want
to be as as chunky as I was as a you
know I definitely could do with a little
bit less fat and uh maybe be the size
you are but play a different position
maybe yeah maybe but I mean that
position was me you know what I mean
like that's what I played well even when
I started losing weight uh because my
last year of football I ended up having
a couple of fights I'll end up and that
was me getting down to middleweight so I
used to be 214 pounds and then I was
fighting at 185 right so I bring that
weight down but I asked so they put me
in a different position
and then ended up just putting me even
though I was lighter they just put me
back into that position because that's
just what I played well so for me uh I
think that's just the best position for
me maybe I could have been a ah this is
that position is called a hooker
maybe I could have played hooker
actually if they wouldn't be happy that
was his position but um but yes that
that was maybe I probably got the right
build for something like that but I mean
my position was always front row do you
have to worry about CTE in rugby
I think yeah I think so um I mean they
hit their head a lot more in American
football or rugby
man a user allowed to contact the head
right like you see people dive with
their head and stuff over their hands on
the case and rugby no no so we're not
allowed to make contact like you were
trying to avoid the head contact right
so if you now it's like back in the day
was a lot worse
so if you hit the chest and they come up
and took the head like it was okay where
now you make any contact in the head
it's a penalty so it's uh the contact on
the heads
you know they're definitely taking care
of that and I think Anita a lot of
people are probably upset with it
because it slows down the game and
obviously a lot of it was accident but
they're just trying to take care of the
athletes which is fair enough sure
you've got to look at it that way
um now our
Journey you're not a particularly flashy
guy like with all the money coming in
the the percentage participation and the
pay-per-view profits like do you have uh
like like what's your most extravagant
like uh luxury and spending
yeah you're right I'm not I'm not I'm
not crazy though I mean I just uh love
uh my holidays with the family really
okay and they're expensive so having to
move the kids but probably that man like
because I'm a I'm a pretty relaxed chill
dude man like I'm just right I will get
like you know I do have like maybe I've
got myself a Rolex watch that's probably
the most I've ever spent on myself which
is obviously not not cheap but you know
I don't usually do that like again I'm a
chill dude just before a couple of hours
ago I'd grab the fishing rod went down
to the lake where I live by myself and
got some prawns and then chucked a line
in and went fishing by myself like you
know I mean like a lot of people in my
position probably would do that you know
what I mean they probably go yeah that's
just
this is who I am so I'm uh I'm gonna go
I'm the same guy was uh 12 years ago and
I say that all the time but people that
know me will can will agree with that
you know I mean not much not much has
changed which I'm proud of but uh yeah
for me yeah maybe holidays you know
spending uh you know they're spending
money on uh holidays would be expially
when everything's last minute like and
if you plan ahead the holidays can be
much cheaper but we never plan ahead so
we plan last minute of when the flights
are quadruple and uh everything's just
uh through the roof but that's the
easiest way to to do it for us but yeah
that I'd have to say that's what it is
which I which I'm happy that is that's
what we do for Americans holiday would
be vacation vacation okay sorry vacation
yeah we consider a holiday like a
certain day of the year that like
Christmas yeah okay around the world
says holiday except for Americans right
right like the metric system and the
pounds it's like we're the only people
that expectations well what kind of car
do you drive
second hand though so I've got a uh
Jaguar so I've got a F-Type uh yeah so
f-typer Jaguar which uh I wanted a just
a smaller sports cars should I get from
A to B uh and uh yeah I like the look of
it yeah so uh yeah so we did to be
honest but I didn't spend too much much
on that but I mean yeah maybe the car
and uh and the watches are the most I've
probably spent on yourself yeah so I
don't go too crazy I understand you cook
we're gonna do some cooking for Steve I
love some cooking yeah for sure and this
yeah a cooking show that you have on
YouTube it is on YouTube yeah yeah and
and uh are we gonna cook here yeah so
we're gonna well I'll do two of them so
a lot of times I do my own cooking so
it's cooking with Volk okay or it's me
eating so I call that bulking with Volk
so yeah yeah so we're probably just
gonna do a bit of bulking with bulk so
what I want to do I wanted to you know I
was talking to guys here at Bayside uh
Cafe that there's the chefs uh gonna
make us uh because I I got this wrong
too do they are they really allowed to
say that you're the UAE the official
people yeah
I called it I didn't even know I'll be
honest I didn't even know what it was
called so I called it a pestarian
we'll make some uh yeah some cool things
and I wanted to get your hot sauce
involved cool yeah so we're looking
forward to that so yeah
yeah try to
keep secret okay
out of curiosity how quickly would you
turn around this uh cooking show because
it would be great if we put them up at
the same time and drove traffic from
this podcast to your cooking show oh
yeah no luck yeah like yeah we could
just uh yeah what day is it today but
we're gonna put this thing up this week
well yeah it's it's Tuesday today right
in Australia it's gonna go up on Friday
in uh America it's gonna go up on
Thursday yeah you guys think you could
turn around that quick oh we're lucky we
will turn around whenever you want
really yeah yeah
people can go to well we'll let
everybody know right now to uh
click here yeah this way or this way in
Australia
this will be our first so yeah yeah
click on that that'll be good
just click that son of a [__] yeah yeah
have you have you noticed that the
toilet's been different direction in
Australia is that true yeah all right
you don't know they expected
thing so
no I mean like uh yeah I don't know I
don't know I don't know if that's a
thing it could be a thing you want to
have a look we can go check now if you
want everybody thank you so much man
thank you I appreciate it man massive
feed and now let's pleasure meeting you
yeah cool